it's a toxic nightmare in Ohio the lack
of answers on that catastrophic train
derailment is infuriating residents who
are too scared to go back into their
homes and officials are not doing much
to convince people it's actually safe to
return the video is coming out of the
town are horrific fish chickens and
other animals are turning up dead or
becoming extremely ill and the people
wonder if they're next
constant smell of burning Plastics and
chemicals in the air issues with our dog
vomiting acting lethargic the fish are
dying so how am I supposed
to bathing my children
stay in the town longer than an hour
before I have a giant migraine I do not
feel anywhere in this town to say we
basically nuke the town with chemicals
so we could get a railroad open I mean
when you watch people that are
investigating they all have these giant
hazmat suits on but somehow it's safe
for people to go back to these homes
Dana putting Biden's EPA boss on the
spot after he insisted there's nothing
wrong with the city's water
would you return to these homes now
would you feel comfortable bathing your
children in the water or drinking that
water based on the results of those
homes that have been tested if those
test results have come back and said
that the air quality is okay and the
water is okay I would remain in my home
and I would drink the water but there
are some homes that have not been tested
for water quality and for those homes
they should continue to use bottled
water until the state comes in and tests
that water Ohio Governor Mike Dewan was
asked the same question on if he would
return and give a pretty revealing
answer listen
I would be drinking the bottled water
and I would be continuing to uh
find out what the tests were showing as
far as the air
I would be alert and and concerned but I
think I would probably be back in my
house
and mayor Pete's not off the hook
there's a big town hall tonight in
Palestine where residents are going to
be able to grill officials for answers
and the congressman there is promising
to save a seat for the transportation
secretary Dan it's a nice job with the
EPA guy
what was your read on
his level of honesty
oh I didn't think he was being dishonest
but I think that what we found in the
morning was like that was in the 10
o'clock hour and the nine o'clock hour
we interviewed the congressman from that
area Republican Bill Johnson and I asked
him are you are you satisfied with how
the Biden Administration is doing and he
said yes from what I'm hearing on the
ground the federal government is doing
what it needs to do we're getting the
resources that we need I don't know if
the problem is at the state level but
with the what I did feel that the EPA
administrator understood but doesn't
know how to deal with is the lack of
trust from the community about the data
um he's saying that the tests are saying
that it's fine but the people actually
don't believe that and the people who
are there as you saw from our reporting
their report they're saying that they
are getting headaches they're
uncomfortable or they're they have
children that they're afraid to put in
the bathtub I understood that when I
heard that because you can get bottled
water and drink bottled water I can
understand that that's an expense but
you can do that but when the woman said
she was afraid to bathe her children
that really struck home to me because I
don't know how that fear leaves and then
later on in the day Martha McCallum had
an interview with this young woman who
said she doesn't necessarily necessarily
trust the data and what she's really
worried about is she's worked hard she's
saved up her money she bought a home
and now she's afraid that that
investment is going to be worthless and
that's really sad you can't blame
Americans for not believing what the
government tells them Greg at this point
why is the government telling them to
wear masks
I mean doesn't this seem a little bit
more dangerous but they're not they're
not everything's fine why do we have
federal government it's to manage the
big National crisis and Boards basically
it's catastrophic insurance you know but
the welfare state changed everything uh
we went from America the fireman to
America the nanny uh and a crappy wanted
that instead of being capable of of
addressing National crisises we're
talking about meaningless ones like you
know what ethnicity is the construction
worker uh do the flight attendants have
non-binary uniforms this guy this White
House reminds me of the last Blockbuster
right it's got some empty store with a
manager half asleep in the back clock
watching between meals no idea what's
going on and absolutely no customer
service if you want help from the
government they only pick up your call
if you owe them money right they'll help
you to your wallet but when this happens
where are they they have no answers they
have no answers for anything right
they're like they're like a paid escort
only if they're only into you if they
can get into your wallet imagine if they
were in power during covid at the start
there would have been no operation warp
speed not at all and I and I'm saying
that with you know hesitation about the
vax for some people but overall that was
a pretty amazing thing never would have
happened with these guys these guys are
so slow it's ridiculous Geraldo here's a
sound bite from Aaron Brockovich you
remember she was famous for this movie
kind of similar situation with the
environment let's listen and you can
react
by not showing up by not addressing this
that a national train derailment of very
hazardous information you do nothing but
create a vacuum of an upset Community a
misinformed Community a distrusting
community and it adds to rumors
speculation losing trust and a lot of
theories act like you care about what's
going on in your backyard in this
country
Geraldo she's great because she speaks
very frankly what you have is two beats
going on here dress you get the expert
beat and you got the local beat now you
got to go with your gut you have a baby
and you have another baby on on the on
the way would you allow your little ones
to be around that environment what is
your instinctive reaction you're not an
expert in toxicity or in the environment
or this or that but you love your
children and you have a rehab
instinctive reaction the instinctive
reaction when I see that plume of black
ugly smoke is what the hell am I gonna
take my baby here and I think that
that's the problem I I like Mike dewine
and I know him he's an honest guy but he
doesn't live there you know Johnson the
congressman Dana mentioned the it's on
the program this morning he he lives
there and I I like his Tempo but still
I'm not bringing my kids around there
and I I fear I I I feel for those
parents
with limited means their whole life is
invested in their homes they have
mortgages
now their homes are basically worthless
what happens to them how will they be
compensated but trust your gut trust
your instinct never ever you know listen
to an expert drink the water then uh
regret it later yeah when the experts
are telling you not to trust your gut
that's where the the lack of trust comes
in you know the issue is why are we
constantly begging for answers I mean
you know why are the public servants who
work for us not out there giving us
answers why are they not on the ground
why is dewine not get and I like to
whine too he's a good guy but why isn't
he on the ground in Palestine why is
Buddha judge not on the ground why is
FEMA not on the ground now FEMA wasn't
on the ground because they weren't asked
in I don't know what that's about but
you know what you've got are people
saying 20 miles away they can still
smell it that tells me that there are
problems from the Ohio river and all the
tributaries and I talked about this
yesterday but the truth is that this
train with all of the damage that we're
seeing and that no one has yet had a
grip on because how do you establish
that the EPA says it's safer not safe
what what Solutions have they come up
with what tests have they done in 10
days give me a break and the truth is
said this train was not designated as
having hazardous material because of the
lobbyists in Washington who allowed this
amount of hazardous material on a train
and so as one of the residents said they
nuked to town so that they could get a
train to keep a railroad to keep going
this is about the politicians in
Washington not being on the ground for
us demanding answers and not getting
them whether it's about a balloon or
this and it's about people saying oh
you're okay and forgetting about you and
the truth is they should be on the front
lines and they're not and it's not safe
and until someone is willing to write it
down you get your family out of there
you know what's interesting about this
story though that I I actually have to
pay a compliment to social media I don't
think any I think that's where everybody
heard about it yeah me too it wasn't it
wasn't from the government didn't say
anything and everybody kept going all of
a sudden on Twitter you're seeing these
pictures and you're going and we're
skeptical about every picture we see now
who knows it could be doctored it could
be from another era but it's like and
all of a sudden it happens and then it's
true and then the government is kept
running after social media trying to
catch up it's kind of interesting you
noticed that today in preparing for the
Americas Newsroom show and the make
Michael Regan interview that you just go
on U.S EPA Twitter page to say like what
are they talking about and it they have
a pinned tweet you know the one up at
the top is about this disaster it is but
everything else after that was like
Valentine's Day how great it is to work
at the EPA et cetera today though this
afternoon there they've been tweeting
like a storm of course you know but they
give all kinds of money for hurricanes
and floods why isn't there Federal money
now for these people to move well there
should be but the governor dewine has to
ask FEMA to come in and he hasn't done
it yet maybe he thinks it's not
necessary but I don't think you should
be thinking that unless he's a scientist
one last Quick Point yes the railroads
are in the rails themselves are in
woeful condition 15 of the Year ailments
are because of cracked rails we have to
pay attention to the railroads the
railroads keep this country going they
are really the artery in this country we
need to spend a lot on infrastructure
maybe that could pipeline go there hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else